and I think it's decreased a lot it's
not a matter of a little in almost all
portions of the globe noteworthy is Asia
which has a more benign view of the
United States generally I am one of
those who thinks the world wants us to
regain our former stature they need the
United States fully engaged across the
board in the defense of human freedoms
and human rights I think it can be
regained I think changes in the
administration in the first instance
will do it to some extent and I think if
we again try to be great in the conduct
of Foreign Affairs without being
arrogant we can rapidly regain a
position which most the world wants us
to have